a video has gone viral of a daycare
worker
forcing a little
kid i don't know how old is this kid two
or three years old
to wear
a face mask
[Music]
there you go keep it right here
[Music]
look we're gonna keep it right here
[Music]
i can't watch anymore
that woman who is doing this should not
only be fired she should be in a just
society she would be arrested tried and
banished to some pacific island as far
away from civilization as possible this
is insane behavior
one we know
statistically from the data that
children are very very very very very
very very very unlikely
to face any serious consequences of the
coronavirus
now if you're saying well the kid has to
wear the mask to protect the adults we
know we were just told that the vaccines
are extremely effective at preventing
the people who receive the vaccines from
facing serious consequences from
coronavirus presumably all of those
adults have had the vaccine and if they
won't get the vaccine then surely the
answer to protecting themselves is not
to muzzle up a little kid who doesn't
even know what's going on that's sick
that is sick behavior that's sick people
in a very sick country doing very sick
things
the answer to that is not well let the
libs do whatever they want well live and
let live gosh i'm going to avoid new
york huh let's just split the country
now the answer is hold these people to
account
and pass laws not that that's the actual
way that we're really governed much
anymore by passing laws usually through
some random agency actually that's where
the vaccine mandate's coming from some
random unaccountable executive agency
but do what you can wield political
power in such a way that that kind of
behavior is illegal and that when people
do it they face consequences for it
offer a standard offer a political
vision and then have the guts have the
have the spine to actually enforce it
this is something conservatives
you know even in the sort of
freewheeling last few decades where
they've lost a lot of their political
mind
sometimes they'll still hit on the right
policy the problem is they've been
they've had their brains so turned to
soup by by shallow
libertarian slogans or neoconservative
slogans that they refuse to actually
enforce anything well it would be wrong
for us to tell that daycare worker that
you can't muzzle the little kid why is
that wrong well you know
you even heard this from some people on
the abortion issue
well look i oppose abortion because i
don't think it's good to kill babies but
i would never impose my view on others
well why not you impose your view on
murder laws on some murder laws at least
you impose your view on traffic laws you
impose your view on rent laws
you impose your view on laws against
theft
sometimes i guess before blm riots
started up
so why not
why what is the hold up here
what is the hold up here i'm so glad you
like that clip if you wouldn't mind
leave me a comment here on youtube
subscribe but more importantly
go to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show click that beautiful little
subscribe button maybe leave a five-star
review if you're feeling generous we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you